two-way tables are something that we've
met before to where tables we've
encountered these actually all the way
since like year eight you nine to be
honest and so these are not new things
but we're going to do a few different
things today with them number one well
we just want to refresh our memory
what are these why they're useful I'm
gonna introduce a bit of like finer
technical language around it but we
didn't really need to talk about before
and then actually super excited at this
because I put a lot of time and effort
into it I'm gonna show you how important
they are despite how like ordinary
looking they seem to be I want to show
you how important they are for seeing
through people trying to trick you okay
so let's have a look at this these
tables are called two-way tables because
we're going to be comparing two
different forms of data on this table
you can see at the moment I've got these
four numbers in here too this way it's
through that way but a two-way table can
be much larger and you'll see examples
of this later on so long as you're
comparing one thing against another it's
two-dimensional that's what we mean by
two my table now you might be able to
guess the M and the F in this particular
table when you're thinking about ways to
break up a population where you
recognize they're for now and female
good guess of course they don't have to
but this is just what the data that I
got was and this is male and female
drivers that are being compared for when
they get you know random breath testing
and that kind of thing okay
so what we have you look at here is the
breakdown of male and female drivers on
a random breath test we're looking at
their blood-alcohol content right and
does anyone know what is the test did
you pass what is the particular
blood-alcohol concentration that's most
important when you go through a
breathalyzer
zero point say it again it's 0.05 okay
so what we've got here pretty cool it's
like 10 times what's right that's
exactly well this is this is small data
so 0.05 used to be the important number
okay
so we've got two groups of people the
top one as you would hope because it's
smaller these are the people who are
breathalyzer over the limit so we're
just going to mark that as greater than
0.05 and then these guys down here
actually I should say that's greater
than or equal to these guys here
underneath this much larger group are
the ones who are below that limit so
these are these are the safe ones okay
blood-alcohol concentration now a
two-way table is useful because you can
take these numbers and we call these by
the way here's the first bit of extra
sort of technical language here we call
these guys a conditional distribution
these four numbers are a conditional
distribution
because they show us the frequency as
the name suggests based on particular
conditions show me the frequency if it's
only the female drivers I'm interested
in
show me the frequencies if it's only the
ones over the limit that I'm interested
in okay so we call each of these
conditional distributions what you can
get from these is these things on the
edges because they're on the edges we
call them marginal distributions because
they're on the edges it's these totals
here that I'm interested in now like I
said we've seen this before can I ask
you let's get a total for the number of
male drivers who were tested the number
of female drivers the number of drivers
male or female who are over the minute
and the ones who are under grab your
calculator out punch the numbers in I'll
give you a minute or so to get the
calculations done can someone tell me
the number of drivers who were over the
limit in total that's an easy one 33 we
can just do that when we didn't need a
calculator for that what was the total
below the limit
1705 okay excellent
male drivers 988 thank you
few more drivers Jackie yes 750 exactly
okay great now when we come to this
final one here right we got these
numbers by adding vertically we got
these numbers by adding horizontally we
get this number how what are we adding
to get the entire groups right these two
here if we add them up they should be
equal to these two here right so
importantly you don't up a data before
you just choose your column or choose
your row what is the total by the way
one seven three ain't fantastic okay so
we've got our total total now the
questions I'm interested and you might
be able to see based on the questions
I'm asking here the question I'm
interested in is can we make can we draw
any conclusions about the relative
safety or risk-taking behavior of males
and females in this driver population so
the first question we might ask is well
what percentage of the drivers who were
actually random breath tested what
percentage for a female now
I'm not interested so much in the number
we'll get to that in a second but which
of the numbers are we comparing to get
the total proportion of females which
two numbers will we divide by Sophie
what do you see
okay well we'll get to we will all get
to that but which numbers will you what
we divide by what to get there okay see
it's the total female Noma and then this
is the general population yet do we
agree with that okay cool let's go ahead
and do that so that's 750 over 1 7 3 8
that's a really gross denominator so I
expect we gonna get some weird decimals
we want a percentage can I be at one
decimal place so again yeah if you
divide if you multiply by 100% you'll
get a percentage at that so someone got
a number for me four point four point
three four point three percent that that
seems my spider-sense is tingling it
feels like it should be more like forty
forty two point nine do we round that
right okay okay someone's doing on your
own which one is it
okay we're revising all right forty
three point to the one five the five
rounds up yeah
forty three point two we got there in
the end okay I was like yeah no this
this definitely doesn't look like four
percent okay have you times that's good
the next question I want to ask is of
the general population considering male
and female drivers alike what proportion
of them have a blood-alcohol
concentration above them again I'm most
interest in the UH trinova
I'm more interested in which numbers are
we comparing 33 that's the one that's
over right over good question which two
numbers we comparing we I think we all
agree it's gonna be this one because I'm
not interested in male-female so it's
gonna be these combined what do I divide
by do we reckon it's this number down
just yeah just just completely flat it's
how many have gone over of our total
populations so it's going to be that 33
over again the entire group yeah 1 7 3 8
that's a very messy 8 okay this will be
a considerably smaller proportion I hope
someone calculated the percentage one
point nine one point nine percent that's
to one decimal place okay now I'm going
to pause for a second and this for this
next bit rather than tell you what I'm
gonna ask I'm gonna let you think about
we have many different numbers we can
compare here and what we're interested
in is can we make some kind of
conclusion is there a conclusion to draw
that's interesting about the difference
between the male and the female
populations within this okay now I'm not
going to tell you what question to ask
or what to divide I'm gonna give you a
few minutes to maybe chat with the
person beside you and work out what
would you divide by what and then what
conclusions could you possibly draw so
let me give you two or three minutes
then we'll come back together if you
think you have a finding and how you got
it call me over okay the question is
yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to get a
sense of this is the general population
everyone that way you breathalyze I want
to see if there's any significant
difference here between the males and
the females within this population is
there any difference between them can I
get that out of this data okay now the
reason I'm not telling you what question
to answer is because actually when it
comes to data this is the real work like
when I told you what to divide by what
there's no there's very little brain
activity happening you don't have to
make any judgments or justifying these
decisions but in the real world you get
the data and you decide what questions
to ask so have a think like I said two
or three minutes if you have a finding
let me know I'm interested and I'm
already giving you a bit of a clue
telling you there's a couple of numbers
here that I think are going to be
valuable to us I'm interested in what
your theories were for what further
calculations we could make here that
might yield inside does anyone want to
theorize any suggestions any takers
go ahead Zaki mo and I thought it would
be important to compare population of
men and women respectively they went
over in comparison to the rest of their
general populations that was a very long
and pregnant sentence let me see if I
can write I think I think these are the
numbers you're talking about you're
interested in the number of people in
the male and female populations
respectively who went over the limit
within their population did I get that
right good okay do you have a different
suggestion she might be or more on this
so sorry is your question about am i
including just this group or both groups
is that what your question is okay so so
Jackie is comparing these two numbers
with these two numbers is that right did
anyone think that we shouldn't compare
those sets of numbers what do you think
so yep oh yeah please okay all right
now it's now it's personal Sophie now
it's okay alright well let's let's run
with Zaki suggestion and see where it
takes us has anyone actually already
worked these out anyone anyone else okay
max which one did you work out if if
you've or have you worked out both
already tell us one of them which one
said it again which one you looking at
okay so can we write this down so what
will we call this group this is the male
drivers with a blood-alcohol
concentration that was exceeding yeah or
or equal to okay so this was what did we
say to two point six percent to one
decimal place okay now the first thing I
noticed before I even go anywhere is I
can repair this immediately to the
previous number right so this is the
general population and this is saying to
us and you can even see this number is
very close to a thousand right so you
could have estimated that that would be
about two point six this numbers already
above the general population can we
cross-check that with the female
equivalent exactly if you said you've
got this number already where'd you get
zero point zero point nine which is
almost it's almost a third of this
number here isn't it so we talked about
proportions right now this is really
important because you can actually draw
conclusions of this not only can you
insurance companies do and that's why if
you are a male driver especially if you
are under 25 you are in the highest
risk-taking category and therefore have
the highest insurance premium by a lot
by a lot all right